first and foremost I think this is one
of the most original clearest authors of
our time and of her generation and
please a warm welcome to Chimamanda
Ngozi Adichie
[Applause]
[Music]
Thanks thank you thank you for being
here it's sexual to like to have you
here in Manchester and I purposely kept
the intro brief because I wondered I'm
sure this doesn't happen to you often
anymore but you enter a room
somebody has no idea who you are which
parts of your identity do you sort of
highlight if you're just doing like a
quick elevator pitch
beyond author isn't it beyond author
human you know you know I think it
depends on where I am and I think
identity is such a I find identity to be
such a fluid thing and I don't mean that
I become different people in different
places I mean there are many things at
the same time but depending on where I
am one thing is highlighted more I think
and so on because I have two homes I
live in Nigeria and I live in the US and
I find that in the u.s. it's my it's my
being black that sort of present front
and center and just in ways that are
practical and so an example is just a
few days ago I was going to board my
flight at Washington DC dollars Airport
and I'm going into the premium line and
the guy standing there says that way
ma'am and he points to economy because
and I realize it's it's this is why
identity matters it has real
consequences so that because it comes
with all stereotypes and so he assumed
that looking as I did I shouldn't be in
that line right and other people just
don't walk past but he's like man you
know good economy in in Nigeria that
wouldn't happen because most people look
like me and I think maybe in Nigeria
what would then be more but the
forefront would be my my ethnicity and
my gender right so it's it's it's kind
of it's always it's it's always I think
identity something won't always
negotiates but it's also often something
that's external so something it's
something inside and outside as well I
identify very happily now as black but I
didn't always
because I became black in America when I
went to the US to go to university I
realized oh I'm suddenly something else
called black and it's not to say that I
didn't know that my my skin is the
glorious color of chocolate but it's
that which I wouldn't change for
anything by the way but it's it's that
idea that there that there's meaning
attached to skin colour in certain parts
of the world and I had come from Nigeria
where really skin colour didn't have
meaning ethnicity had meaning religion
had meaning and then to come to the US
and to be in a class and to write an
essay which the professor said who wrote
this this is the best essay and I raised
my hand and he looked surprised and it
was a very small fleeting moment and it
was maybe my fourth week in the u.s. but
that's when I realized to be black is to
have people make certain assumptions
that you cannot write the best essay for
example that you need extra help with
school walk for example how what are
your thoughts on identity and authorship
I know that some of your very earliest
writing as a child was informed by the
stories you were reading I seem to
remember something about there being a
lot of snow in those stories even though
you didn't really grow up with them can
you maybe reflect on I guess the role of
identity in writing and where you feel
the perhaps the tensions may or may not
be just to roll a little second question
in there because I'd love to just hear
you reflect on all of this I know that's
in America there's this new thing seems
to be going on about own voices this
idea that we want to hear from the
people who are actually from a community
or have a particular identity or cetera
do you on the whole see that as a as a
positive development or is there also a
a danger that we only want to hear about
black people from black people white
people white people women from women etc
I think it's complicated because I do
think we need to have more voices we
need to have because I think
storytelling is is doesn't exist in
vacuum there's always questions of power
and access and so I think that many
people who feel very strongly about that
are coming from a good place but there's
always a danger I think of them reducing
things and becoming very reductionist
I'm a keen believer in having more
voices having more stories having
different kinds of storytelling but at
the same time I do believe that there is
such a thing as the ability to there's a
wonderful line I like which is that's
really true choice to become a life in a
body that is not your own and I think
that sometimes also to tell stories is
to inhabit bodies that are not yours and
so I want to be able to tell whatever
story calls me I don't want to feel
constrained if I choose tomorrow to
write a story about a woman who lives in
Stockholm and it's blonde and blue-eyed
I want to be able to write that but but
I think that the question is to do it
well and I think that's where power
comes in so we live in a world where for
so long Africa Asia Latin American
stories have not been told by people
from there right so that you go to a
bookstore and you you go to a bookstore
in London for example and go to the
Africa section and there are many of
these books by you know sort of still
have a colonial sort of tinge to them
and it's not that we don't those stories
are important you know I want to know
how England wrecked Nigeria it's very
important what bonds because you know
actually what's happening in the world
today we look if you look back
historically I find it's so interesting
because I think if you look back at
what's happening all of our we're
talking about Hong Kong a few minutes
ago in all of those places and now we're
living were being haunted by the past
that's what's happening today but anyway
I won't go into a rant about that I
don't think we have the time but no but
I remember what I don't remember what
the what we were saying I think he
fudged answered it the identity in sorry
and I think I think you've lost largely
answered it but what I actually wanted
to follow up with on there
is the sensitivity around all this and
maybe that's quite a nice bridge to more
generally language literature but
generally also just discourse in this
room and everywhere and comfort the need
for comfort and staying away from
discomfort and I thought this would be a
good moment to bring in my personal
favorite Americana and which you have
once reflected on as your [ __ ] you book
and they are not saying this to
embarrass you it's probably you may
disagree but it feels like the most
perhaps the most honest clear language
in there
very unfiltered and for those who throw
those two people in this room who
haven't read it can you can you start
with just maybe talking us through a
little bit you use your protagonist has
a blog and and you seem to use that as a
device unless I'm completely
misunderstanding it to sort of speak
unfiltered if you will can talk us
through Elizabeth that by the way I
think it's more than two people I think
some gentleman there like we don't know
what the heck but don't worry you
haven't missed anything if you haven't
read it but I you know I wanted so and I
did say it's my [ __ ] you book and I
think I maybe had a glass of wine before
I had that interview because then these
things haunt you I feel like he's
sitting but I do what I meant and I
stand by it it is my [ __ ] you book
because it's I wanted to write the book
I wanted to write and I I I felt that a
lot of literature was very that in the
name of nuance people were not being
honest especially about things like race
in America and so I wanted to write a
novel that I felt had a kind of what in
some ways I call it cinema verite
equality but I I want to have a lens
with which I'm looking clearly at the
society that I now call my home and but
but fiction still has certain
expectations on certain requirements and
so I decided to use this blog as a way
to kind of subvert those expectations so
in the blog my character takes on this
persona where she's she's I'm hoping its
I wanted it to be funny because I
when I was writing it would laugh you
know writing and then I was start to
worry that I was laughing at my own news
because then you're like led it's
raining thank you
but also I think you more tea more and a
certain kind of just in your face mess
to talk about things in ways that I
think we shy away from and we shy away
from those things sort of using the
language of art and nuance and
complexity which sometimes for me just
equals dishonesty right race is a real
thing it's a real thing because it has
real consequences in people's lives but
it's also very complicated and complex
and also sometimes quite absurd and I
wanted to use that blog to write that in
a way and I and I knew very early on
from my editors response that that it
would be beautiful interesting she
talked about nuance she's like we need
we need more nuance by which she meant
take all the honest bits out well um
maybe with this book but more broadly
have you ever run into the phenomenon of
sensitivity screeners and perhaps more
broadly what do you make of this and
maybe you can explain for those who go
on tell what it is but what do you make
do you worry about this trend I didn't
when I when I wrote America and I mean
quite it's been a few years so
apparently the sensitivity screening
thing hadn't become a thing right
so sensitivity screening is is something
where you write a book and then
sensitivity readers read it to find out
who can't possibly be offended and what
what you need to change I think this is
an absolute disaster for storytelling I
I think that to tell a story means that
the only thing that one should focus on
is truth and for me it's emotional truth
as well as you know truth the truth and
somebody you know the my feeling is that
storytellers do not ever start our real
storytellers never start out
deliberately to offend I think that we
now live in a world of people who
provoke for for a living but that those
are not real storytellers in my opinion
people who tell stories are telling
stories because they're seeking truth
and you know maybe somebody will be
offended maybe but I don't think it's
healthy for storytelling for the
enterprise of storytelling to have
sensitivity readers because in the end
you just need to flatten the story right
you're going to we just need to take out
every bit that's interesting but but I
don't want to be too flippant about it
because it's also important to I think
acknowledge that again I think going
back to storytelling and power there
have been stories told about different
communities different groups different
countries that have been offensive
sometimes deliberately so and being
Nigerian being African means I grew up
reading lots of books about people who
were supposed to be African who I found
so stupid that I identified with the
European storytellers because I thought
surely you know these people that I
thought I was because the Europeans were
always the sort of the smart ones who
made sense the African characters were
always really stupid oh the noble
savages so I thought no these people are
foreigners to me yeah I am
so there's a history of that in the
world and I think I think it's important
to correct that but I do worry that
there's the likelihood of overcorrect in
that we're now you have you know books
where you're reading them and you're
thinking but put your line right but
this isn't actually true on actually
just really briefly and on talking about
race I was recently working on an
article on diversity and inclusion in
the workplace and quite a few employers
told me that they're very comfortable
talking about gender now because they
were one told me there's completely off
the record they all have wives or
mothers and they find race much harder
because they are worried to offend in
the in the words of several and I don't
want a now Maurice are they white
I don't want to ask you because I mean
no you were often asked to represent all
black people but if you what would you
say to people like that who were - who
are who are worried about saying the
wrong thing and therefore leave the
issue all together I think we need to
emini to become more comfortable with
being uncomfortable but I also think
that I think we now live in a world
where there's a kind of enforced
orthodoxy of language and I think it's
very dangerous so they're people who
don't know what the latest ward is and
when they don't use that latest ward
because they don't know it somebody
comes after them so that kind of
Orthodox I find very very dangerous I
believe very much in looking at context
and intent so I'll tell you a story a
friend of mine said oh my parents who
and so he's talking about you know
elderly parents Chinese parents and he
said I'm so offended because my parents
used the word Negro to refer to a black
person and these are parents who you
know I'm kind of out of touch they
probably watched 1970s American
television when Negro was the war to use
and so they use it today and this person
is very offended and I remember thinking
actually I think those parents mean well
they think it's still negro they're
actually trying to be polite right so I
think it's important to look at context
and intent and in talking about
diversity we have to make room for
discomfort and we have to believe that
that's going to lead to a better place
because we sort of have to think of it
as moving through discomfort to get to a
place where you know utopia that's the
ideal but but I also sometimes think
it's too much of an easy cop-out for
people to say oh I'm uncomfortable so I
don't want to talk about it let's just
leave it yes and the reason I asked the
race of people who are saying this is
that if you're black or brown it's
really not an option for you you you
because you're living with it and the
consequences everyday so it's you can't
say I'm comfortable so I won't talk
about it actually you
want to talk about it because it affects
your experience in the workplace for
example and so you know this idea that
I'm uncomfortable I won't talk about it
we need to talk about it we need to
embrace this comfort but I also think
that we need to make room for people
saying things that are awkward not
because they're evil but because they
don't know I believe it very much in
sort of this idea of Education and I
know that there are many people of color
who feel very upset about it who feel
it's not my responsibility to educate
you but then I wonder well whose
responsibility is it no no I'm with you
and briefly let's talk about girlhood
and feminism and you said earlier you
became aware paraphrasing you had but
became aware of being black when he
moved to the States
when did you become aware of being a
girl I don't know I mean I I don't
remember a time when I I actually may be
I think maybe it was one of those days
when my mother said something like you
know you need to know how to clean and
she didn't say to my brothers right and
we all did the same things you know I
play grew up playing football with my
brothers we played badminton in the in
the backyard but then when it came to
domestic things they I was pointed out
like yeah you go and I'd be like what
why right I don't want to go in the
kitchen I was still playing bro I think
I I think for me
recognizing femaleness came as as a kind
of recognition of the things from which
I was excluded and and as a child I
asked questions it just didn't make
sense to me no just didn't make sense
I remember when I was in I was in grade
3 and my teacher had said if you get the
best result of the test then you'll be
the class monitor and I want it to be
class monitor especially because if your
class monitor your teacher give you a
king and you could put you sort of
parade the class and point out the noise
matters
use it well I wanted this power very
much we imagined just that the high up
holding a cane instead of walking around
going you're making noise you're making
noise but that so we do the test I get
the best result that my teacher says oh
it has to be a boy
and I remember thinking about why and
she said but he just has to because boys
and when it does and then the poor boy
who was second on the test didn't want
to be he was just this lovely kind sweet
sue who didn't want to hold the king but
then he was mid the monitor and I
remember that that's for me it's stayed
in my mind because it was so glaringly
unfair I mean that for me was that
gender was just so unfair and made no
sense but also just observing the world
that I I knew very early on that I lived
in a world that did not give to women
the same dignities that he gave to men
and the reason it didn't do this was
because there were women and again as a
child I just thought this makes no sense
so I don't remember I really don't
remember a time when I didn't know that
I was a girl um your book why we should
all be feminist was distribution to all
16 year olds in in Sweden and at which I
thought was oh it was it was a great
gesture and of course it would be Sweden
right that leads the way with something
like that just very briefly and I sort
of underlined the all in in this
question why we should all be feminists
is that in trying to broaden the church
if you were in trying to make it really
inclusive and big and getting everyone
on board with feminism is there a risk
danger do you already see it happening
of diluting it and making it meaningless
I think that's a very good question um
and I I think the answer is no because
because it depends on how one views
feminism if we think of feminism as a
sort of an exclusive party then then yes
but if we think of feminism as I do
really as a justice movement you know
fundamentally it's about liberty and
justice it's about really being allowed
to be individuals and so for me we
should look at feminism as
thing as a sort of a vehicle to create
the kind of society we want and to get
to a point where we no longer need
feminism but the goal of feminism should
be to make itself we don't don't
and to do that I think we it has to be
mass movement and I'm also a feminist
who feels very strongly that men have to
be part of it I don't think we cannot
change we live in a world of great
gender injustice everywhere in the world
everywhere but we cannot change it by
only changing women
it just won't walk you know men have to
change you have been reading about a lot
about domestic violence because I'm
researching it's it's just mind drinking
and so killing to just look at these
statistics and I think it's important to
have all of these programs for women how
to protect yourself how but what are the
programs for the men right we need to do
more with that we need to so for me to
broaden feminism means to make not just
women you know it's always it's making
women responsible for their own
oppression we shouldn't do that right
and so I feel strongly about things like
when we start off very early in raising
boys and girls differently you know
giving boys the language of emotion
because we don't um giving girls the
language to reject likeability because
we raise girls think you don't have to
be nice you have to be liked and it
starts very early right when the little
boy falls down in the playground
we don't really hug and kiss him or like
oh you know get up your man when the
girl falls like oh right
but at the same time when the boy breaks
things we say oh he's a boy when the
girl breaks things were like you're bad
I feel as though we need to sort of get
to a middle ground where we do the same
things for both right we both give them
room to break things because I wish I
had more room to break things when I was
growing up but also where we give boys
the language of emotion and we give them
more hugs right when he falls down give
him a kiss don't tell him to man up
because he to you know maybe he wants to
cry we should I read
you feel very strong I know it sounds
it's almost simple but giving men the
language of emotion and starting very
early I think will make a huge
difference and even the rates of
domestic violence I really do believe
that on that note men don't be afraid to
join in here let's let's get some
questions let's get some questions from
the audience I see lots of men with
placards that's great
that gentleman over here and then
perhaps gentleman over there on the
front thank you you have very lovely
here I I wish I could wear my like that
but you mentioned you live both in the
States and in Nigeria is here female
here as political in Nigeria as it is
obviously for black women in the States
I'm so glad you asked that question I
think I think the short answer is not no
right not quite as political and I and I
think the reason in the u.s. hair is so
political black woman's head I think
women's hair is political right in the
way that you know white women have to
cover their Gray's that sort of thing
but black women today in particular and
I think it's because America is a
country that is deeply racist and so
race becomes a thing and hair becomes a
thing in Nigeria not so much because
Nature has don't care we just like
whatever
everybody has a long weave that reaches
their knees and they're just fine but I
think hair is political for black women
in the sense that only I think that
black women really are the only the only
people in the world who are expected to
change the hair that Nature gave them in
order to fit what is called a mainstream
ideal and so to have natural hair then
becomes a political statement when you
don't want it to be right in the way
that when white women let their gray
show people think oh maybe she's crunchy
and she does yoga right um but maybe she
just doesn't want to put color in her
hair and so when a black woman wears her
hair natural they're like maybe she's
very black power and very Angela Davis
and you know
but actually she just doesn't want
chemicals in her hair but their
consequences for it because she goes for
an interview and people are already
thinking she's not a good cultural fit
because she's wearing the hair that God
gave her I find that to be just a deeply
sad thing and it's going on today I have
many friends who have dreads in the u.s.
and they go for interviews and already
you can tell someone's looking at you
thinking you're not a good cultural fit
and the evidence for that is your hair
but that's actually the hair that God
gave you right so you spend so much time
trying to change yourself to fit a
certain ideal and and we don't realize
how much that can that kind of sort of
energy from your spirit it can so when I
decided to wear my hair natural I mean
even my mother thought this was terrible
she's like you need to do something
about that hair it's changing a little I
think but there's still a certain
bravado that one has to have to wear
your hair natural they still a subtle
[ __ ] unis to doing it and even that is
exhausting right it would be nice to be
able to just wear your hair right and
just even braids I think my sister here
probably has some experiences right even
braids is a problem like a cultural fit
I've so many follow-up questions you
want to ask you but I can't because we
need to share the stage actually let's
take the lady on the second row in the
middle and then the lady right behind
her so red and green why do you both ask
your questions and if somebody got a
microphone to get in their direction do
you mind taking to to your mother do you
mind taking to questions yeah let's just
get them both and then my it's really
really nice to hear you and and be here
as part of this event so I study I do
research on multicultural individuals
and so what you said about identity and
other people deciding for example your
blackness how do you or what would how
do you deal with and what would your
advice be to people who get an identity
they never even thought of like I don't
know in my case terrorists
so it's not an identity that you
obviously identify with but other people
are giving you an identity so how do you
deal with the external identity that
people give you my question great
question hi it's so lovely to hear you
speak today I wanted to ask you
mentioned that the goal of feminism is
to ultimately make feminism redundant
and that obviously ties into a lot of
other equalities like I think it's not
on uncontroversial to say ultimately we
don't want our race to be a deciding
factor in anything that we do and I
study international relations which
involves discussing lots of fun things
like war and structural inequality and
spending all day talking about that and
all of my classmates are yeah like yeah
this is deeply unfair that we live in a
world where I'm not gonna make as much
as my parents or my gender is going to
define me or my race is going to define
me and then one day my professor said
all right so give me an anecdote of what
you think a wall will look like without
any of these things and just the scope
of that to people my age is so insane
it's like wait what do you mean I don't
have to work till I'm 70 to make a
living what do you mean to do that
so in your words could you give an
anecdote of what you think what the day
a day where these sort of movements are
successful will look like that question
I I don't think that when we reach the
goal of making feminism redundant
eradicating racism and all of those
things it's not going to necessarily be
a utopia we're not all going to get
along we shouldn't all get along okay
but I think what the difference will be
that the differences will will be more
substantive and be about so I will then
so the woman who goes for an interview
will not get the job because she's just
not bright or just not knowledgeable
about the subject rather than because
she has dreadlocks or because she's an
observant Muslim honest combat right
that's I think that's what it would be
and the idea of not walking until you're
about to drop dead from old age
shouldn't be so radical
I mean even if we go back in history
that the societies where yeah people
didn't walk until they're 85 and died
and and maybe also we need to question
and I know this is the economy's but you
know whatever we need to question the
way that capitalism is is walking out in
the world for us today right because and
this kind of capitalism that is so
relentlessly about profit and growth I
mean do we get to a point where we've
grown enough right do we get to a point
where because I think that's also part
of the problem that's that's that's the
reason why people have to walk until
they're 80 that's the reason why you
know young people can do it that's the
reason and and if we're not addressing
that then I think there's a dishonesty
there so it's really not to me something
that's inconceivable I think it's very
doable but um and and the question about
I'm sorry I found it very funny but in a
very dark way because I completely
understand I can't tell you how many
times I've been at airports at
immigration and I'm and there's a woman
in front of me who's covered and
thinking they're going to stop her and
they always do because you know she has
to explain terrorism in the world I
think that the identities that we don't
that I imposed on laws I think are the
most difficult because it's sad to say
but you don't really have a say in it
and again this is why I think maybe
storytelling makes a difference I think
if we tell more stories of people I
think even simple things like a Netflix
show can start to change the perception
if we humanize people right if we start
to see that that a woman who chooses to
be covered you know isn't necessarily
this terribly oppressed woman who will
you know wear a bomb and go whatever
storytelling matters because it
humanizes people we start to see my
goodness this is a human being like me
and then we're less likely to think that
if you look at particular way must be
that you accept particular things it's
it's no I think putting it that way
makes it no it's not your well it's your
job if you have the opportunity if you
work at Netflix it's your bloody job to
make sure that you get more Brown
stories told yes it is because you know
the other
thing is you know reading this book
about them dates and women and data and
a lot of the things that are in the
world have a male stereotype like that
based on the male archetype actually I
was just doing a little rant with Sasha
about I have this handheld is because
those mics were not made for women
there's you know because then somebody's
poking around your bra put the thing in
because they're made for men who wear
jackets and you can stick it in right oh
I don't and so in general even holding
this for me is a feminist act of
defiance because I'm late but the reason
I say that though is that a lot of these
things the people who made that mic are
not evil sexist they just forget we men
because the world is so male and so when
I say that it's your responsibility I
think that whiteness is the norm in the
world and sort of white Western stories
are the norm so when people are making
decisions about what shows to air that
sort of thing sometimes they don't
remember right the women in the Western
world who make the choice to be covered
and the strong women which is why people
like you need to go in and remind them
so I'm sorry darling but it's kind of
your job you and you slightly
anticipated my ending question so I'm
gonna put in a new one
and my question was going to be about
the social utility of literature but I
think in a way you've kind of already
answered you know the importance of
storytelling in that so rather than do
you want absolutely no I think I think
you've done well learning on that I
wanted to ask you about group versus I'd
individual identity I can imagine or
rather I know having having watched a
lot of interviews with you there you're
often asked to be a representative of
all sorts of things to have the answer I
recognized a very small sliver of that
I'm often asked as a female journalist
as a woman who how do you deal with that
tension of group identity versus the
individual how do you fight against sort
of that individual identity that are
getting crushed out against the group hi
because you also recognize
that especially in a female journalist
that's not the norm so you do kind of
feel the need to put on put represent
but then on the other hand there parts
of your individuality that don't
necessarily align with that I don't know
which is to say that when people ask me
to talk about Nigeria I'm thinking if
only you knew how many people in Nigeria
think I'm crazy then you shouldn't be
asking me to talk about oh but but I so
it's it's kind of a constant negotiation
it means a lot to me that my my sort of
my presence in the world means something
in particular to women to black women to
women of color to Africans that means a
lot to me right I do feel a sense I find
it quite moving so it matters to me
this idea that hopefully my you know the
right thing that I do
opens doors for other people who look
like me that kind of thing but also
sometimes it worries me because there
are people think you know if you're in
Africa and if you're an African feminist
if you there's a way to be I think my
whole life has been about wanting to
shrug off that idea that there is a way
that I should be because all I want is
to be the way that I am and that's where
identity can't become a big constraining
I get emails from Nigerians who say you
know you represent Nigeria you should
not write in your book about people
having sex but that's not African you
know I get people who say to me you
cannot call yourself a feminist because
that's not African and I just think well
it is now because there you know I mean
but it's always a constant yeah it's a
constant sort of balancing act because
you there are times when I really chief
against representing the whole you know
what people say what is it like to be a
like I don't know thank you for
representing yourself here today it's
been a tremendous pleasure having you
here please thank you I know
you